so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
make me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys making sure you
guys could hear me fine let me adjust
some of the settings a little bit
people was asking how long it takes to
do
this
this loop man that's what people was
asking so i figured you know what's the
best way
of explaining how this loop works is
just streaming it
felt like that was the best way
so pretty much
i already got the
the scenario we take this is the
scenario we take
i already did all the research uh this
it's pretty much like showing what
happens when you actually do an entire
playthrough
all good on audio wonderful man so let's
go and get this started we go to carl's
bay first this is the first place in the
game that you go to after you figure out
where everyone is what kind of scenarios
you need to do this is the first one
keep in mind this is spoilers i'ma i'ma
literally beat the game
the vast benefits for all humanity
you're not benefiting anyone out in this
place
it's interesting
all right so first off this is due to
the right we got a handle
let's go and hack that
we don't want them seeing us when we're
crossing the uh the alleyway
let's get rid of him
i might get seen there
the good thing is their bodies disappear
i've always enjoyed that
oh god
that took way too much hits
it's perfectly fine guys it's not the
end of the world
we just been seen a little bit
all right anyone else see that's one of
the issues i do have with the game
someone else should have heard that but
no one else heard that
like they were shooting right next to
these people over here they should have
been very aware of that one man
i'm not feeling the fact that that music
keeps playing so what we're going to do
here is we're going to sabotage these
fireworks
so it kills another one of our
targets
what's going on uh
jared mac
what's going on man appreciate you for
coming through man
appreciate you for coming through
so we're going we got to get in this
room but we don't want to be seen so the
best way to do it is just use blink and
get on top of this
this should be this dude right here
we're gonna go ahead and handle her with
the oh god
i can't believe i just got seen there
oh my god
you know what
let's just restart
man i can't believe i did that
i had the wrong melee weapon on
that was my fault i had the wrong melee
weapon on
nah we're good we're good
we're just gonna start the day over
again
we we messed up at the beginning man we
messed up at the beginning where the
lords go i fall i appreciate it jared
man always been a loyal supporter man
always been a loyal supporter
so we're going to restart the day
that was my b
get a little bit too into myself man get
a little bit too into the game play made
a couple bad mistakes you know i should
have been a little bit more
fluent on how i handled that but i
wasn't so we're going to restart the day
uh because i don't mind dying just not
there we're not going to die there
uh we we need to be a little bit more
open to uh
the scenario uh what we'll probably do
is switch out a loadout real quick
because i don't really
let me see what kind of
i don't really have anything for him
this nexus is a little bit different
um
i wish i had some upgrades for this but
i don't
we're just we'll just keep it like it's
not hurting no one we'll just keep it
what's up nama omar how you guys doing
man how are you guys doing is the stream
sound fine do i sound fine sorry my
camera's not on uh just you know i
didn't i didn't feel like having the
camera on today
let me make sure the camera isn't on
okay so the camera's fine there
so we should be good
attempt number two fellas attempt number
two chat we got this though
not everything's done on the first
attempt man not everything's done on the
first attempt
so we're gonna pretty much go the same
route that we went last time
take out this dude here
then we're going to disable this
what's going on eric what's going on
get him so when i cross here
there's not like a lot of issues going
on we don't want to be seen yet
the stream's great
all right now let's not have this issue
that we had last time
where we were seen
let's let this
get up a little bit more
let's get as high as we can without
being seen jump up
then we're good there
um
we'll go ahead and do
this part here
got you
wow
i'm not restarting that
i'm just gonna kill him
yeah i'm not restarting that we still
got another we still got plenty of room
let's get my
my uh essence back though
all right so let's open this like i said
we want to disable we want to jam that
then we're going to go back up here
go to the other end here
drop down
this time let's wait for them to stop
let's not just
randomly hit i want to have accuracy
here
all right so he's dead
let's climb this for no issues
let's switch abilities now we want to
have the ability where we're invisible
all right so let's let's give a couple
seconds to get that back
let's hit it back up
just in time for the show we're gonna
want to go up here
all right so we're good there it doesn't
look like no one saw me
oh yeah we have to go over there
[Music]
oh hopefully this dude doesn't see me
the good thing about is they're pretty
drunk so they're not gonna see much of
anything
all right let's open this door
let's kill her
can't have her being seen
don't want to be seen
we're going to be slow man we're not
going to go straight into this
i don't want no one seeing me
like here
all right so we're good there
all right i'm not going out i'm pretty
sure she goes the other way
you have she's looking for
no more
all right so she's dead it's a little
bit sloppy but we got it done
all right let's absorb her soul
get us some currency
this nexus upgrade
oh people know where i am
that's fine
where's the exit
i think there's an exit right there
no there's not an exit here
we got to get out of here
should be a door
all right we're good we're good we're
good
let's get to the exit
as long as we stay to the rooftops we
should be fine should be no issue
getting back
all right let's get out of here
let's blow this joint
[Music]
we killed another visionary
got that stuff going man we got it going
so now we've killed two people it's time
to start the next
one next two we have to do we don't have
to kill no one in this next phase
all we have to do is sabotage some stuff
so um
because if you could tell these two are
still
these two are still uh messed up so
let's go ahead
and go here
we have to sabotage this dude's stuff so
he goes to where we want him to go
right now what's pretty much happening
is if if i don't prevent him from doing
this experiment he's going to end up
being at the end of the game somewhere
else that i actually want him to be so
in order for him to go where i want him
to be i have to sabotage his thing
all right so we're not we're in a
different part of the map so it takes me
a couple minutes to find where we go
the confluence is probably the uh the
part the the map
in death loop i'm the most unaware of
probably use this sniper to be honest
with you
i appreciate it man
see that blue light i'm at the disable
that probably not you know i could
probably go this way
now there is a visionary the people we
have to kill she is in this building i
can show you to you real quick
uh but you don't have to kill her
oh it's locked right now
where is she
there's one
two
they don't know where it's coming from
three
i'm sure he's tripping
he's just sitting there they falling man
they falling
it's fine though
got him
so let's get over there where they are
let's go and disable
this oh no there's someone still alive
we can't let
him see us if we don't absolutely have
to
all right so let's take care of this
now i do got the perk on
to where this thing
takes a little bit longer
we can hack this quicker
let's hack this little thing here oh
it's not there i guess it's there at a
different time of the day so we're good
right now
another one down
that's a long shot
i don't think i'm comfortable trying to
shoot that
so do you see the news
no i didn't see that news they bought
next month um
tag me on twitter
uh
so i can make a video on that
because i'm working on my death loop
review but it's not done yet
oh i didn't i wouldn't have even known
she was there she didn't talk
should be one more yep
now there's a one up at the top
oh
where are you going
where are you going
not trying to be seen by home dog here
all right so
let's go and hack these
so they don't kill us when we go in here
then we'll go through here
[Music]
and just deactivate them
they go down here
oh
let's hack that deactivate it
let's turn this down
all right so we powered everything down
we're good there
now what we need to do
is we need one of these
open this up
we need to set it up like right here
it's gonna make this pop out
c805
five
oh five
so that pretty much makes it so where
edgar
won't be doing this when um
he won't be doing this later what he'll
do is he'll do something completely
different
because if you don't
stop that from being made what happens
is edgar comes back here in the last day
and we don't want that we want him going
where we want him to go so i deactivated
it so he won't be doing that at the end
of the day he'll be going where i want
him to go
[Music]
let's see what's going on next
let me see here
uh people people clowned me on twitter
did they beat this game
i don't know
i don't know
let's infuse
all right so we're good there
so now we got to kill two of them for
the price of one
we got to go two of them next
we'll see how that goes man we'll see
how that goes
people coming at me hardcore on twitter
because i died that first time man i bet
you they even beat the game
i appreciate you
uh making hit that like button if you
guys enjoy it man
you guys hear that sound there's a bunch
of traps and stuff around here
i'm probably going to get hit by this
one over here because i always do
it's that one right there
oh not this time
we good this time
so pretty much what we found out with
this
is zero four forty one is there is two
of them that
have this this fleeing
and we're trying to take advantage of
that
wow it froze again
wow it froze
can't make this [ __ ] up man
wow that's only second time that's
happened to me
let me just go ahead and
debt the game and re
do it because sometimes it saves between
uh between area so hopefully it saved
when we went into that area
man i can't believe it did that again
it that's the second time that's
happened to me and ironically they both
are on stream
[Music]
not a good look man mr maddie plays cole
eastwood and victor is saying microsoft
announcing
their purchases of these studios next
month that's interesting
it does look like they saved when i went
into this area
hopefully
i don't know yet but we'll find out
yes they did
so we're good man we're good i mean it
still
is a drag but at least it wasn't like
the entire area they really need to fix
that menu glitch
because sometimes you have to go into
those menus
and if you can't go into the menus then
clearly it's going to be hard to do
anything
oh
there's a trip mine there
there's a trip mine there
trip mines everywhere
we don't need to deal with any of the
trip mines though we're gonna go
straight past them all
straight past them all
so zero four
41
24 and 16.
ah
zero four
41
24
16.
door open we good
now pretty much right here
is we found out where two of them uh
beat up
no i'm not using a a keyboard a mouse we
found out where two of them meet up and
now we're going to kill them both for
the price of one
now i don't have to kill them
myself they're they're they're they're
having this fling in this damn around
around here i'll i'll be quiet so you
guys can hear it
[Music]
this is two of them
keep in mind i've killed them
individually multiple times
that teleport move came from that
charlie dude right there the one that's
crazy
and um there's a move that makes you
pretty much like really
hard to kill
oh one one one saw
me he can teleport too so i need to make
this quick
oh god i need to make this quick
see now i just turn on the emergency
plumbing so they're gonna run straight
there
i don't want no smoke from her
we got to get out of here
come on
they're dead
we got to get out of here though
so we want to climb the this this
let's just jump out and go to this
that's how you kill them too
now they're gonna drown down there
and ain't nothing they could do about it
i did that a little bit sloppy though
one of them saw me
and then after that first one saw me i
officially stopped carrying so i just
ran
i i hope they don't get out though they
might get out i don't know
i've never had them see me
yep got them both
so that's two down
let's grab that we're good on that
let's go back to the beginning
let's run
um
autofill
got to get back in there man
there we killed two of them
now we could have easily have just
killed them both individually and got uh
got all the currency that they had on
them and got their runes but it's easier
just to flood them and drown than it is
to fight both of those because you got
to keep in mind one's got like some
protective elemental shield that she
could put on her and the other one can
teleport the ability that i've been
using so i don't want to i don't want to
mess with none of that
not trying to fight any of that
i really should have probably
switched my secondary
because it's easier to kill
uh the last two people here
jiff turkey i have no clue who that is
i don't know if you're trolling i don't
know who that is man
i have no clue who that is
all right so let's go ahead
a little bit of frame rate issue there
shoot one nail put in like eight that's
funny
oh homegirl's all after me
so that's the pvp aspect now there is a
uh
a real person that's after me so i got
to be a little bit quicker man i can't
let her get me
i'll probably hack that switch so we can
leave here in a minute
he's a youtuber i was wondering if you
knew him he's a good dude no i don't
know him man i don't know who that is
i don't want anyone seeing me
but what we can do is hack that
oh she got me i don't even know where
she was
yeah this is live
home girl got me and i didn't even see
her
she's right there
it's easier to fight them oh [ __ ]
i just killed remember how i sabotaged
that thing at the beginning
that's that's how i just killed that
dude
this chicks stressing me out
she's still up here yup
what's up home girl
enjoy tomorrow
yeah see
she got too comfortable she didn't see
me jump down
oh a shift upgrade i've already upgraded
my shift though max i believe so
at least we don't have to worry about
her anymore
she decided to show up at the wrong time
that was unfortunate
oh my god
all right so
nice play yeah i i knew she was the the
moment i saw on that rooftop i knew it
was over because i knew she didn't move
any and i tried to run up to her quicker
because i didn't want her like turning
around at the last minute and getting me
so now we want to get this dude
um
he's got a thing he likes
shut this door so they don't notice it's
shut
let's shut this door
gotta get them both really fast so they
don't call for help
let's switch this up i don't want to
have the same issue now there's a lot of
traps down here and it's not too bad to
handle
just got to make sure that we get that
yeah
we got him though
let's disarm all these traps
because if you hit one it's a rat they
they'll know because the party's right
above us so we have to like be really
careful
that we don't set none of these traps
off
[Music]
all right so all the traps are gone now
this is how this is going uh the target
that we're eating now he likes beer and
he likes a pacific kind of beer and
there's beer on the tap upstairs now the
way to get him
is he likes this beer so what i do is i
turn all the tap down and i guess he's
like the engineer or something so when
you when you shut off all the time
he comes down here to fix it
it took me a while to figure this out i
had to stalk his ass for a little bit
so you want to cut all these off and
what's going to happen
is he's going to take off
he's going to come down here
so we want to chill wait here a couple
minutes for him
let's wait up here i like waiting right
here
all right so i didn't yeah i shot that
we're good
damn he came down here fast
that's not him
i don't know why he was down here
that's never happened the dude screaming
is the dude i'm trying to kill
okay so he's coming in here
we want to get him the moment he gets in
here
that's him there
we're going to snap his pretty little
neck
so there's the other one done
let's absorb his
his soul
and what power did he have he has carnis
he has like the telekinesis ability
let's grab all these
let's go and go invis we don't want them
seeing us
now
i might be able to get up there
i don't think there's anyone up here
just in case let's get on the move
all right the next person's over here
there's two over here uh remember how we
sabotaged that
uh that science and i said we didn't
want him be in that other place at the
end of the day
well when you sabotage it he comes here
because he's got to think for this
this chick over here
so there he is
and there's the chick he's got a thing
for
last time i threw a grenade over there i
didn't do a whole lot they didn't die
from it
so i might try to shoot the chick over
there first that's why i was i should
have picked another ability because the
other ability i have it will link them
all together i don't know what he's
doing is he talking to himself
he's probably trying to get the courage
to hit up this uh
this doctor that he's got a thing for
i don't i don't know which one we should
kill first this dude here
he's got the ability to turn invisible
it's this ability this is where i got
this ability from
she
doesn't really have an ability
all right so we got rid of one of them
oh god
you want you want the smoke
got her
oh god
boom
snapped her net
all right so we got her
let's take his ability
come on come on come on
hurry up
take that
let's get out of here
we no longer need to be here we've
killed everyone we need to
don't want no one seeing me
stay to the shadows
so we've died we haven't died yet that's
good
nope
gotta go over here
jump down use double trump at the last
minute
now this is where the the chick that
stalks you
she's in the secret uh unc undercover
bunker
short hand now
you got to do a lot to get in here
now the this is the way you get to the
last person in the game the only way to
get to it is to kill all the other seven
people
we killed freya
that was the chick with charlie that was
in that thing we drowned both of them
they gone
over edgar was the dude that would invis
the one that i had to shoot a couple of
times i had this ability
frank was the one i made explode why i
uh i sabotaged his fireworks alacus was
the dude that went down there to get the
beer
uh that's the dude i got in that
basement that went down there wendy is
the um
is the doctor the one that i said that
um
that uh edgar had a thing with that was
her
and then uh the one above that was the
uh the chick i killed at the very
beginning the first one i killed so now
that i killed all seven i'm able to go
into this
and then this will take me
to the last place in the game
it's where the other person is the
eighth person
here we go
snappy we good man we good we good up in
here
[Music]
come on
oh
all right we're good we're good
a lot of extra stuff man
and keep in mind this is hours and hours
of learning those patterns and learning
what i can do and learning how i can
manipulate the situation and learning
how i can get all those people in the
same room that i did at the very
beginning of the game if you don't do
the
the the pattern in the way that i made
it guess what happens you kill them all
individually one at a time
uh you bet
we've done this before
haven't we
she has a treat for me
she's in this room
[Music]
she gets rid of all my slabs all my
abilities
case are dueling pistols vintage pieces
original oil cartridges completely
unique
kind of
dusty they're museum pieces
part of history worth preserving
like black reef
please sit
well she knows that i she knows i've
done it man
did it ever never got to a scenario
where she's the only one left
so if we survive the collapse of the
loot you'll wake up with the barrel of
my gun in your mouth dying for real
beats living like this you mean living
with me
you hate me living here stuck in this
fulfilling day you used to like me
you used to see this place for what it
could be
then you murdered me
so you could have a real life without
do-overs and i thought you were ready
for answers
great fine
i get it you've been through a lot
here we go you guys break this place but
that doesn't mean you know how to use it
sure i do
target practice cult
what you want me to write a book paint a
[ __ ] project i want you to ask
questions
about this place
about me
about the other cults
so i can forget the answers like
everyone else what's up mike because
they're bored
you're not bored are you not the word
out of you so
stay i'll show you incredible things
how many times have we had this exact
conversation is there a version of your
fun that isn't us killing each other i
came here to be eons [ __ ] arcanist
you murdered me i appreciate it jared
you guys know i do how much i appreciate
that
i fought back you know you guys have
been very good to me every fight get
good iop in general
i appreciate the support
then it's on me to end it
for everyone you know no one will
forgive you
i won't forgive you it's happening it
doesn't have to
cold
you still have a choice
take the pistol
all right so let's talk a little bit
before i pick up this pistol
now
what's gonna happen when i pick up the
pistol
is we're gonna have the opportunity to
for us to kill one another should i kill
her i don't know she might pick up the
pistol and shoot me if i take too long
but should i let her shoot me we don't
have all night you know i feel like
she's gonna pick up this pistol and pick
it up so i'm gonna pick it up in five
seconds
four seconds three seconds two seconds
one second
zero i'ma pick it up i'm gonna pick up
the pistol
should i shoot her or let her shoot me
last time i shot her i don't know what
happens if i let her shoot me so i'm
gonna let her shoot me unless you guys
want me to shoot her so put it in the
chat if you want me to shoot her or you
should or should i let her shoot me i'm
confused which one you guys want me to
do let's do this
tell me which ones you guys want me to
do i'm about to pick it up i'm pick up
the pistol and pick it up right now
are these antiques even gonna fire if
you pull the trigger
and if i don't okay i'm gonna let her
shoot me unless one you tell otherwise
you don't got much time let her shoot
you okay okay okay it's like fun
on three
i shot her on one literally she just
started counting
oh oh what's going on
oh what's going on
you know
for a second you almost had me
we restarted the loop didn't we
probably get a trophy for not shooting
her
last time i did it she started counting
down she said three i already shot her i
was it i didn't care i already shot her
yeah unbroken loot
i didn't break it
it goes
okay plans what are we doing later i
already got plans party keg stand drop a
lexus in the meat grinder
you know classy night
wanna get a drink after like
with you yeah
i like drinking yeah you do think you
can keep up used to grab the party i'll
bring the beers
that's cool i'll probably get a trophy
for not killing her
uh
you can call uh me uh
dad if you want oh
okay
[Music]
dad
okay that's uh too weird
yeah that's not uh yep
and that's the game
that is the game of death loot after you
learn everything about the game keep in
mind it's like i said it was not easy to
do this
i made it look easy because i've done it
over and over again until i found out
exactly what you have to do
like when it comes to break the loop
like you guys see all this visionary
stuff
these leads i had to do all of this i
had to find out where these people were
i had to find out what their motives
were what they liked what they didn't
like i had to find out where to get them
to go i had to find out who they were
messing with like this dude was messing
with her so i had to get them together
uh i found out that they didn't like
each other so i had to make something go
i found out that fox dude and the this
chick didn't like each other so i had to
make that go i had to do whatever it
could to make sure multiple of them are
in the same place by the end of the game
so this time we're going to protect the
loop i'm going to do this one or two
times so pretty much how this goes is
you spawn is her to kill cole the dude
that we're playing see if any of our
friends are on here
uh no one's on here worthy of killing
yeah i i enjoy the game definitely
catching the iop this sunday i'm gonna
go a little bit more detail on what i
enjoy what i didn't enjoy about the game
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna have to make that video
you guys people are definitely talking
about this acquisition i have to figure
out what they're going to uh buy
i'm gonna start making more videos i'm
starting to feel more
uh to my
my old self so was the gameplay
addictive yes it was it was very good
i i would play this mode more but i feel
like a lot of people are are
just turning off this ability so she's
having i'm having a hard time finding
people
that let me connect or maybe it's like
player based since i haven't played it a
whole lot it's giving me a hard time
finding anyone
no one played multiplayer
look man i don't know but uh you do got
good points man you do got good points
maybe that's what's happening i don't
know
i'll send you maddie's video later i
can't turn i can't turn on my phone in
all right man that's fine
it will eventually find a match it just
takes a couple minutes
it's actually not that easy to be heard
because you can't see where you are hurt
they are and they can't see where you
are
so when i would remember she was on that
church or whatever that building was i
ran to the bottom right and ran across
really fast she didn't see me coming she
didn't know i was coming
so by the time i got there she was still
looking down that because she didn't see
me jump off
i don't think it's cross play i don't
know though
this was on game pass i'll probably find
a game by now
just throwing that out there stole that
out there there'd be more people playing
it
see look how long this takes
man see why i don't do this very often
all right so let's
i'm looking at all this uh stuff going
on right now
man it's taking forever man it's taking
forever
yeah i would definitely have a bigger
pool i don't know how many people bought
this game in general
but i do like this this like little
multiplayer thing
but i do feel like because when you are
here
none of the npcs attack you
and you can actually disguise yourself
as one of the npcs this ability right
here
you can disguise yourself it's a bit
snooze right now it definitely is man we
i just want to play one and show you
guys what it is i'm not gonna like keep
playing them over and over again
and plus it's taking so long
yeah like what i showed you is a
fraction of the game carlos like this
game does take a lot longer to beat
full playthrough slit start to finish no
sleep i've already beat it man i've
already beat it bone you missed it i
already beat the game
ask the chat no voucher man i beat i
beat the game already
i already beat the game
bone it's already done it's finished
that beeping is very annoying
that beeping is that that uh that thing
that you have to disable when you're
cold i think
colt
so we gotta
we gotta find
where she is
so
my guess
is he's either down here trying to
sabotage that
or he's trying to go in here because
there's only real
reason to come in here is is for them
so let's make our way slowly
to
where she is
because uh keep in mind we don't know
where she is and she doesn't know we're
we don't know where he is and he doesn't
know where we are so we're going to try
to
make it go a little slow
i hear shots i think
all right so
there is a way in there from over here
all right so i don't know if he's coming
over here for any reason or
i totally just opened that door for her
if if he was
trying to get her he can get her really
easy now
this door is normally locked so i'm
actually making this easier
i don't have like blink or anything so i
can't get up there
i could kill her for him you guys think
i should kill her for him
be helpful
you know sometimes you need
oh i think that's him what
something's going on over there
oh i
oh he's got he's got blink
where is he
oh
got him
got him
done
over
one and zero i'm gonna keep going till i
lose i'm gonna keep going i'd really
love to invade a friend like i really
love to invade a friend
i don't know anyone in the community
that's even bought this game
i bet you i wish kid smooth was playing
it because if kid smoove was playing it
i'd be able to get him
if kid smooth was playing i'd invade him
easy
you don't have to play this mode you can
actually disable to where like an a an
npc comes in not like an actual person
but i kept it on because i felt like an
actual person is more of a challenge and
i had more enjoyment killing her than an
npc and i saw the ais be kind of clunky
and kind of dumb so i definitely didn't
want to take that ability out of the
game
if that makes sense to you guys
let me ask you guys a question um i kind
of want to stream more but i don't want
to stream on on youtube on the iop
channel like this because i do feel like
in a way
it's harder
like i don't want to clog the channel as
as much like would you guys start
straight if i started streaming on the
twitch channel would you guys follow me
over there be honest like if you guys
wouldn't go over there that's fine i
just kind of get like a little bit of a
head count on the people that's in here
because i know some people don't they
don't mess with twitch at all
so feel free to comment down there if
you guys want to
what kind of games you guys interested
in seeing like i was thinking more of
like party games maybe when mario party
comes out maybe i play that like i was
thinking more about stuff like that like
i feel like in order for me to be a
streamer i'm gonna have to be consistent
and i have to be like real
of just announcing here when you're
going on twitch yeah i could see that
now the iop channel does have a twitch
channel it does have one of them
uh so i was thinking maybe
so should i stream on the iop channel or
should i stream on my own twitch channel
what would you guys think is better for
maybe for the brand it's better for the
iop channel maybe stream on the iop
channel where i feel comfortable enough
streaming on my own
if you guys get what i'm saying
because i do feel like twitch has better
overall quality as well
the connection was filled
ain't that some
[ __ ]
look at that man
we had that that was ours that was a w
for us and they screwed us
sometimes i ain't gonna lie to you guys
like playing her is not easy
i i think it might be a little bit
easier if you play the objective because
a lot of these maps especially the last
day you know where they're going
there's only a few places they would
logically go in those days now sometimes
they might be doing something small on
those war on those nights but for the
most part especially if it's the last
day
they're going to fight them at the end
but sometimes you know because there's a
lot of things you have to do throughout
the game on the last day that doesn't
involve assassinations and you have to
reset the loop but for the most part if
you're on that last day nine times out
of ten they're probably trying to kill
uh a visionary or something like that
and i guess it would determine what part
of the game that they're at as well
if that would make sense to you guys
like
don't cut the server
look man death flip it looks like we're
in the snow place
um
this could be a couple places they could
be they could be going and fighting the
i don't know what i had to find out what
day it is here what time it is that's
what i would have to find out
so we'll see i don't know if it'll tell
us what they i haven't really looked
so it looks like it is the nightfall
[Music]
the conflicts
it's night
alright so
i don't let's go over here and see if
edgar's over here
all right so edgar's not here
looks like this might be the afternoon
like
it's not the evening it's afternoon
all right so let's see who he's trying
to kill he's trying to kill someone
clearly
what is this oh it's a sticky grenade
alright so let's see
could be over here
i like how she recognized me
there's no dead bodies or anything like
that i don't like how i don't have uh
select through the abilities or i would
probably pick different abilities
let's see if she's over here
it's gonna be a lot harder to do about
blink though
still got it though
he might be in here because there's a
lot of stuff you have to do in here
no they're alive okay so maybe in the
power room
he might be in the power room
all right so
not in the power room
let's see if he's in julian uh the vivid
chip
he might be in there
i don't know where he is man
it's like i said there's only so many
places where he would go
we just gotta find him
where is he at
so this is one of the spawns right there
but it doesn't look like he's in there
everyone's still alive so he's not
killed anyone
she's not trying to deactivate this
either
let's look down here
we went over there
confluence
this is another
exit
so she's not there
i would love for them to buy sega to be
honest with you sega is the company i
would like for them to buy
he might be over here messing with the
um
the doctor
very possible
oh it's open
here's the doctor it's the chick that uh
one of the chicks i killed one of the
people i killed at the end
all right so
they're all alive
so she's not trying to kill them
it's got to be in the power generator
but no one's dead so it's like weird
let's go to the other side
i like how they they acknowledge who i
am
are they scared to come out
[Music]
so we we we want real people playing
this
not scrubs
i don't see them killing anyone
i mean everyone's pretty much alive
i don't know what he is doing
he's probably
i don't know i've i've checked there
conflicts is a really whack place to
look i'll be real with you guys
okay let's go up to what's your name's
house hold up
i can't get up there very easy
i mean if he wants to leave he's got to
come here
we don't like people that's being too
careful man
let's go on the disguise
this is another place that like a lot of
you start out a lot is here
i feel like they should be a little bit
more up front of where everyone is
let me be real with you guys
i understand why they're not but
it's
situations like this
that makes it really hard to to like
really play this because now
like i don't know where she is
and i'm looking everywhere
and it doesn't look like what's her
name's even here
what's up fam
because uh
later on in the day this opens up a
little bit more
well she ex she it blows up
so that's why it's not there
that
that chick's crazy and she's in there
alright so he's already closed that
i might just leave and re-cue
stabs notify
all right what is he doing
oh
oh he's here
oh yeah he's here
oh god
i'm nervous
where is he
he was definitely here
that's a fact
he took that
oh there he is
see if i can get him
i don't like going in here
wow i got killed by this
oh
my gosh man those guns will get you
i knew something was wrong the moment i
went into that bubble
and there was a
they had a nola fire there because those
nullifiers aren't up for no reason
they're up for a reason and he he put
them up
caught me off guard i went through there
like five or six times
i didn't see him at all
that was that was interesting man that
hats off to him man that was interesting
he got me
got me fair and square you guys he got
me fair and square
i wasn't feeling that wasn't feeling
that
felt like i could have done better
a little bit felt like i could have done
better
it is what it is man so
what so i see
got killed by sam fisher is that what it
said did it say sam fisher
i didn't notice it mike i didn't notice
this say sam fisher or not
do
it's crazy
[Music]
oh oh no you're playing
oh you got uh man would be cool if i got
matched up with uh someone in the
community man
let me see if let me call kid smooth
hold up let me see if he's gonna play uh
play this tonight
let me call
what's up
are you gonna play death loop in here
tonight
well go ahead and play it
i'll join i'll join with you as uh julia
and i i saw i'll even help you kill it
kill people
it's not that how the game's supposed to
be played but i'll help you
because because i'll invade you uh
because i can invade friends timelines
here
yeah so
just start the game and it should let me
pop into your uh
your timeline
why
yeah that's fine
all right
all right peace
all right so i told him i was gonna help
him
but i'm not really gonna help him
i'm level three look how long it takes
to find someone man
there we go
attempt number three i'm one
and one
this is this is the one that's gonna br
that's gonna answer all of my questions
man i'll probably end the stream after
this probably stream tomorrow too you
guys i'll probably stream tomorrow too
i i do want to start streaming i feel
like i feel like i could improve as a
streamer a lot
stop colt right so where
midday looks like
this is a really good place to
to post up because a lot of people come
here all the time
oh this is in the morning
because this is they don't do this
unless this morning
unfortunately he could be here for
multiple reasons in the morning
now the entrance
is over here
this is where he'll be coming in most
likely
oh yeah so there's no one here so he
went this way
[Music]
there's supposed to be guards here so
he's he's come this way
yep there he is
[Music]
oh my god okay they got me again
we ain't going out like that
we ain't doing that that ain't happening
we doing this again we doing this again
i don't like how i don't have the radio
so i can't deactivate those things i
didn't realize how
how weak you are to those things
i was so focused on that
and what's funny is you guys saw me i
knew where she was i knew where she was
going
what's a he
called to do
but you guys get the point you guys get
the point man that was a mistake
oh my god i'm so stressed over that
i feel like i had that i feel like
i should have played that better like i
let him play me like a fickle like i
should not have been so open with that
attack like that i should have the
moment i saw that guy like i should have
went a different way i should have did
something why did i do that
the world may never know i don't know
why i was so aggressive there like i was
so
aggressive for no
reason
[Music]
here we go man we we're gonna do this
again
attempt
three no this is attempt four
we are one and two no attempt three this
is three
we are one and two
so we have one one times lost twice
i feel like this is a good redemption
moment i feel like i could have a very
good redemption story
stop cole
he's here somewhere
all right so he's not here
all right so
he's probably in that direction that we
just went to
so he's probably over here somewhere let
me put back on the chat
all right so let's try this again
all right so it's blue that means he
hasn't took it over
let's make sure he's not in here
[Music]
i don't see anyone that's not a good
thing
i do see people so it's probably not him
unless he's like really stealth-like
which i don't know if he is or not
yeah i don't see i don't think they're
in here
i think i'd see them if they was in here
by now
yeah they're not in here
that's fine
no biggie
let's go back in there
it'd be the best actually to fight him
there
so he's not in there
i think he went the other way he's just
being stealth
that's the only thing that makes sense
why i can't find him
there's no one here
this is crazy that i haven't ran into
anyone yet
there's no reason for them
to to be so
inconsistent
let's see if these people are alive
they're dead so
i don't know where they went
unless he's followed right behind me
i guess
that's a possibility
yeah same scenario
it's
red not going that way this time
i'm not getting shot by that again
all right so it does look like
he is over here somewhere
where
i don't know
all right so it doesn't look like they
went up there let's check up here
he's probably trying to be stealth-like
blue means that
we own them green means they own them
let's see if he's up here
clearly he's trying to kill frank i just
don't know where he is
he did kill some people
but where did he go
i just don't think he went in here
see there's a there's i don't like going
in here as her because
there is a way that he
can have the advantage in there
yeah i think he's in here
he's trying to kill frank
he's trying to kill frank frank's on the
second floor
let's beat him to frank
frank's in here
he's trying to go to frank first
hold up two could play at that game
[Music]
so let's go no i want to carry you
he's in here somewhere i just don't know
where
i don't
oh the battery blew up
okay
i got worried there for a second i
thought he accidentally i thought he was
shooting
[Music]
i'm trying to to throw these people off
normally
you wouldn't
have you would the where i'm putting
these places at they're not supposed to
be there so it's gonna it's gonna catch
them off guard
if i keep putting these other places
he's around here somewhere
imma get him
what's going on jordy
he's not getting to frank
[Music]
you know it's sad i actually can help
kids smooth if i wanted to
i can open up doors that he can't get to
now let's take it off he's here
somewhere and i'm about to have all my
abilities he ain't about to have nothing
he's in here somewhere because some of
these doors have been hacked
oh yeah that's right i can't go in there
unless i have the chip
where is he i guess i'll go back and get
that chip
i shouldn't need that chip to be honest
with you it's kind of unfair that i need
it
because all the doors are locked unless
i retake that chip so i guess i'll go
retake the chip
because we gotta go in the other room
he's somewhere else in here
ah
yeah
oh
yeah
i don't know why that's so
satisfying that i knew the map so well
and i knew the game that i was able to
know where he was he was somewhere in
there i just didn't know where
oh so you can get more stuff now okay
the nexus
can i get like the upgrades for it
parasite not really
oh man i'm so i'm sure he was so
upset when i just started shooting him
because i'd have been upset i ain't
gonna lie to you guys i'd have been
upset and i think it froze again so
we're about to restart the game again
but i i'd have been very upset if that's
how that went down
but it didn't because i knew he was in
there because of all those green because
when you hack something as as cold it
turns up green it's green neon so i knew
that i was good
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh i'm really enjoying this man i'm
really enjoying like the way that this
game is played
right so there's my shift
so you can you can change stuff
all right so we don't want the spiker
because why do we want to be
we don't want to be stealth like we want
to go in there and shoot these people
what is this i never had the heritage
gun
all right so let's let's look at
all right we don't got nothing i think
when i kill them i get their stuff i
don't know yet but
[Music]
whoa
i'm about to put i'm about to clip this
up nice and light man i'm going to clip
this up nice and like
because it's it's definitely uh been a
good time and i actually like this type
of multiplayer they're just gonna have
to you know put it on that game pass we
got to put it on that game pass we got
to get more people playing it we got to
get more people playing it
got to get more people playing
virginia i appreciate the uh stop by uh
mike i probably won't be streaming much
longer since it's two and two i gotta
you know i got to man i gotta break
that uh that cap man i gotta do it
plus
[Music]
might just go ahead and call it now you
guys these things are taking pretty long
to come up with
yeah i'ma call it now i appreciate
everyone for coming by on the stream man
i i appreciate i'm gonna really try to
be more
uh active on these uh try to try to get
a good streaming pad i'm gonna try to
still make videos on the side i enjoy
making content i really do it's uh very
enjoyable for me i've been trying to
improve a lot of things in general but i
appreciate everyone coming through
definitely be on the iron lures podcast
this sunday at 11am i'll be there i'm
gonna really you know save my gripes
with uh
this game what i like what i don't like
you guys know how we do it we keep it
real on iop so it'll be iop this sunday
and